three layers three secret ingredients
and the perfect balance of textures and
flavors this is the ultimate chocolate
cake
when we set out to make the ultimate
chocolate cake one thing that we were
really going after was a really dark
rich black color and so to help us
achieve that we decided to opt for the
dutch process cocoa which is a little
bit darker by a little bit i mean a lot
of it it's like a much richer darker
color and a lot of that just comes into
the way that it's produced
first things first you want to preheat
your oven and prep your tins for baking
here's a cool trick for making this
really painless taking three strips of
parchment folding it in half
fold it in half again
and then with your eye on this left
bottom corner you're going to fold up 45
degrees
and then fold it again
and then take that point and roughly
measure from the center to the edge and
that'll be where you cut then when it
comes out and you unfold it it's a
perfect circle that fits into your tin
you don't want to get the batter made
you know have those lavenders working
and then not have your tins ready to go
[Music]
now this cake has three components and
what we're going to start with is
sifting our dry ingredients into a bowl
sifting is important because it aerates
the dry ingredients as well as ensures
that there's no big clumps or any other
weird things that would be sitting in
like your flour i don't know like
sometimes there's little bits of stuff
so this just ensures that none of that
gets in your final cake
so the first secret ingredient in this
cake is stout the stout is a lot of
different things but it also adds a
really cool interesting depth of flavor
that you really can't get with just
using water alone
the second secret ingredient is espresso
powder and this helps really enhance the
chocolate flavor the espresso and the
stout are going to give you that extra
boost that makes you think like oh
what's in this it's so good and rich so
we have the dry ingredients we have the
wet ingredients ready to go the next
thing we're going to do is cream our
butter and sugar
you really want to do this for a while
you're not just combining them you're
really trying to get a lot of air beat
into the butter and sugar from time to
time you want to scrape down the bowl to
ensure that you're getting everything
really evenly creamed in together
[Music]
as always with eggs we recommend
breaking them into a bowl separately
first just in case it's like a bad egg
or you get a bunch of eggshell in
whoop
butter and the sugar can only absorb so
much liquid at once so that's why you
really want to take your time and add
one egg at a time
super buttery look at that
now for the third secret ingredient
don't freak out it's mayonnaise
there's a lot of other secret
ingredients that are in chocolate cakes
i've seen anything from sour cream to
sauerkraut we're only putting about a
half cup in here you're not gonna taste
it it's gonna be extremely moist and
rich you can already see how much more
creamy this is making our batter now
switch off between adding our dry and
our wet ingredients so you don't be too
crazy about this just dump you know good
third and
a big part of why you're doing this in
stages is mostly just because if you
added it all at once it would go
everywhere and be a huge mess just take
your time add it kind of every other
optional we're gonna fold in some dark
chocolate chunks what the chocolate
chunks will also do is add like a third
texture to the cake so you're gonna have
this really gooey fudgy cake with that
rich buttercream that we're gonna show
you how to make later and then you're
gonna have these nice little bits of
chocolate kind of that journey of
different textures and flavors
throughout
because we have chemical leaveners in
here with that baking soda and baking
powder you don't want to let this sit
out for too long that's why we preheated
our oven and prepped our tins it's not
going to dome as much as some other
cakes it's actually going to come out
pretty flat which is really great so
we're not wasting anything by cutting
off that top dome we did test a ton of
recipes and we didn't like how a lot of
them would dome so much then you have to
cut that off in order to get good layers
for your cake
let them cool in there pretty
significantly to turn them over the
easiest way is just putting a plate over
top and then flipping them one by one
and you want to put them back on the
drying rack and have them cool
completely before touching them again
you never want to decorate a warm cake
if you put buttercream on a hot cake it
will just completely melt the frosting
the thing about buttercream is it seems
really easy but the temperature of your
butter as well as the temperature of
your kitchen and what you're doing
really makes a big difference if you're
really struggling to get it on the cake
it probably needs just like a little bit
of warmth to make it spread better
more for not making a mess i tend to end
my dry ingredients into the butter
slowly just because everyone's had that
experience when they toss a whole bunch
of powdered sugar and then turn their
mixer on and then there's powdered sugar
all over you in the kitchen
so slowly incorporate your powdered
sugar and add milk as needed now that
our cakes are cooled and our buttercream
is made it's time to decorate
we're going to put down parchment paper
and we do that to keep our cake stand or
platter or whatever you're using clean
so this is my favorite tool in the
entire world an offset spatula is going
to change your life
so as you can see it's nice and flat i
don't need to do anything weird to it
i'm not cutting off any top of it i'm
not going to have any waste and look how
great this color is i mean it's so dark
it's going to be like ugh the best color
i'm going to put a whole bunch of icing
right on top in between the layers you
want to use more frosting than you think
this doesn't have to look pretty it
doesn't have to be perfect if you put a
whole bunch in the middle and kind of
push down it'll help get the icing all
the way out to the sides
a nice thin layer all over the top and
then what i like to do i don't know if
this is like a pro tip but i like to
kind of dab with the back of the spatula
distribute frosting all over
then you can start smoothing it i would
say when in doubt just add more frosting
than you think it's much easier to take
frosting off than it is to try and work
with a little bit of frosting and try
and spread it out evenly if you can't
get a really even layer what you could
do is kind of go for that rustic look
and take the tip of your spatula and do
little s's back and forth and just kind
of like dot it all around we're not
gonna do that but that's like a little
tip for you if you're going crazy my
struggle was decorating cakes is i never
know when to stop and sometimes like
you'll just keep going and going and
going and it was fine like five minutes
ago just stop don't keep going you could
go on forever it looks great put the
spatula down
you can put anything on here you can put
shaved chocolate you can put you know
sprinkles you can put shaved coconut a
whole bunch of stuff i love the look of
just fresh fruit on everything
to get that perfect slice you want to
run your knife under hot water or put it
in like a pitcher of hot water every
time you make a cut clean it off if you
have icing and crumb all over your knife
and then you go and cut down you're
going to carry that all into the next
slice
it's really well balanced between the
cake and the frosting not overly sweet
you learn a lot of fundamentals with
this recipe that you can take with you
in a lot of other cake recipes that you
do
journey of textures throughout this cake
i know i'm taking this to kind of
extreme guys but like this is the
ultimate chocolate cake and i tested
this for weeks so trust me
i also i'm a big fan of fruit cut in
half
just wanted to put that in there for
everyone